hello
it's the first time lorraine's seen her
mum this year hello mama and today is
her birthday
[Music]
birthday a special visit even if it is
just the two of them but from monday a
change in the rules means the limit of
visitor numbers will be lifted it's good
news yes because it means the rest of
the family can visit her now as well
she's got grandchildren great
grandchildren that want to see her
so
it'd be great for her
you're doing it open first
oh
this one's from gracie may the easing in
england comes after two years of on off
restrictions allison moved into the
olive tree care home here in bristol
just before the pandemic struck
she's got great nieces and nephews she's
yet to meet now i can actually make up
for lost time it's going to be great
you know my whole family together
you know the things we've been missing
for years and years and years it'd be
absolutely fabulous but the easing in
rules is just a few days away
managers are nervous
about fully opening these doors after so
long the word unlimited i think is a
little bit um
too wide-ranging really
what we need to
be able to do is to manage people's
expectations of what is going to happen
if suddenly we have you know 10 people
per person living here arrive on monday
we'll have 650 people here you know it's
just not feasible so we really need to
be able to manage people's expectations
for you staffing in care remains a
serious problem
the government insists holmes will be
able to use their judgment if coveted
numbers climb there is a lot of
discretion i think that is right because
a you know one care home may have for
example a lot of positive cases another
may have none so there's a lot of
discretion we now be able to begin a new
chapter we see omicron in retreat and uh
and we begin the road of trying to find
all the best ways to learning to live
with kobe we've all spent two years
living with pandemic laws and finding
that best way to live with the virus
isn't just a challenge for care homes
many supermarkets are continuing to ask
shoppers to wear face coverings a
similar decision on transport networks
and while rules differ across the uk
there is finally a broad easing of
restrictions
this latest announcement for care homes
in england
is a welcome move towards normality for
families who've gone too long apart
thank you
dan whitehead sky news in bristol